Android 6.0 Marshmallow
brought a major change
to Android's permission model.
Instead of asking for all
permissions at install time,
it introduced a runtime
permission model,
letting you control when your
app asked for a permission.
When and how you ask for
a permission is critical.
It's kind of like asking
someone out on a date.
Doing it too soon, too
often, or in the wrong way
isn't going to go well for you.
I'm Nick Butcher,
and in this video
I'll walk you through
the details of Android's
runtime permission
model and show you
how to design a UX for
asking for permission
that's appropriate
to your app's needs.
Now, the purpose
of permissions is
to protect your users' privacy.
When you ask for a
permission, you're
asking them to give up a
little bit of that privacy,
and as such, you need to offer
a clear and equal benefit
in exchange for that access.
Runtime permissions allow
you to choose the right time
to ask for a permission when the
user has more context about why
you're requesting it and
the benefits of granting.
You might be familiar
with runtime permissions
from other platforms,
such as the web,
but the way that
Android implements
them makes it incredibly
important to ask
for them in just the right way.
You see, Android's
permission model
favors protecting the user,
so when your app requests
a permission, Android shows a
dialog letting the user accept
or deny it, but it also lets
them say never let this app ask
me for this permission again.
Now you want to
avoid this outcome,
so we've designed the
system to effectively let
you ask for permissions without
having to be overly defensive.
The very first time you
request a permission,
we don't show that dreaded
"never ask again" checkbox.
We'll only show it after a
user's denied a permission
request at least once.
You can check if you've
been denied before
and be smart about when
to provide more education.
This lets you build a
smooth journey for your app,
only adding extra steps or
information when needed.
In particular, you don't need
to be too defensive, like always
screening for interest
before actually requesting
a permission,
essentially, asking twice.
This double prompting can
be unnecessary and annoying,
and you can achieve
the same effect
by asking at the right
time and in the right way.
We broke down the
different approaches
to asking for permissions
across two dimensions.
Firstly, how important
is the permission
to your app's operation?
And secondly, how clear is
it why you are asking for it?
Depending on these
two factors, we
recommend different approaches
to how you ask for permission.
If the need for permission
is both critical to your app
and obvious why
it's needed, then we
recommend asking up front.
For example, if you
are making an SMS app,
then the SMS permission is
absolutely critical for you
to function, and it's crystal
clear why you're asking for it.
Don't bother your users with
any unnecessary explanations.
Just request the
permission straight away.
If a permission is really
important to your app, but not
immediately obvious
why, then we recommend
educating before asking.
If your app uses some
kind of user onboarding,
then this would be
a great opportunity
to tell them about
this killer feature,
then go ahead and ask
for the permission.
So, for example, if a key
part of your note-taking app
is that it logs the location
where you made a note,
you'd want to educate your
users about that up front,
and then ask for the permission.
Next up, if a secondary feature
of your app needs a permission
but it's clear why,
then ask in context.
For example, if
your note-taking app
lets you dictate an
audio note, then it's
pretty clear why this
feature would need
the record audio permission.
There's no need to bombard
your user too early
with this request.
Better to wait until they
try to use the feature when
it will be immediately obvious
why you're prompting for it.
Finally, if a feature is not
core to your app's purpose
and not immediately
obvious why it's requested,
then you should
educate in context.
So, for example, if
your note-taking app
lets you collaborate
with friends,
then requesting access to your
contacts might be reasonable,
but it isn't immediately
obvious and would benefit
from some user education.
When the user
invokes the feature,
offer some explanation
of the benefits
it allows, like autocompleting
email addresses,
and then let the user
opt into it, only
then asking for permission.
By using the right approach,
it should be clear to the user
why you're requesting
a permission
and what they get
for it in return.
This doesn't, however, mean that
they'll grant the permission
100% of the time.
So how should you handle denial?
Now remember, Android lets you
know if the user has previously
denied a permission so
that you can show more
rationale to educate them
on why you are asking
and the benefits of granting.
If a user denies a
critical permission,
then explain why you
can't proceed without it
and link to your
app's settings page,
where they can rectify it.
Don't just shut down.
Now, this is
especially important
as the user may have checked
that "never ask again" box.
So your app may receive
the permission denial
without the user seeing
the permission dialog,
and it could seem like the
interaction was just ignored.
Another pro tip
is to always show
the user immediate benefit when
they grant your permission.
Like we said, this
is a trade-off
of access for functionality.
So, for example, if
you are granted access
to the user's contacts,
then you could immediately
present a list of their favorite
contacts for quick selection.
Finally, while
you're taking stock
of the permissions
your app uses,
perhaps revisit if you
need the permission at all.
Android offers facilities for
apps to talk to each other,
letting you delegate
tasks to other apps.
For example, if you want to
allow users to take a photo
but it isn't a core
part of your app,
consider using intents
to ask the camera
app to take the photo
and share it back to you.
Voila.
No need for the
camera permission.
So that's Android's
runtime permissions model
in a nutshell and
some approaches
to asking for permissions.
Now that you understand
how it works,
you can craft the perfect
flow for whether, when,
and how to ask for
permissions, maximizing
your chance of
your users agreeing
to hook up with your app.
Thanks for watching.
For more information,
check out these links.
[MUSIC PLAYING]